Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday, October 10th, 2017, and I'm sitting on a hotel floor in New York City,
which can only mean one thing: my new book,
Turtles All the Way Down is out now,
at least in the US, the UK, Ireland, Australia,
New Zealand, and several other countries.
First things first, if you've already read the book,
thank you! I hope that you liked it.
Also, please do not spoil it for other people.
Okay, so I've created a spoiler-riffic subreddit— [DING!]
Hold on, that's the elevator.
Oh man, it's 'me's all the way down.
I can't decide if I should wear a suit.
Oh, look who I picked up, it's a Hank!
—Hello.
—Right, but to return to the topic at hand, I have created a spoiler-riffic subreddit for Turtles All the Way Down,
where people who have read the book can go and discuss it with each other,
and also ask questions of me directly.
There's a link in the doobly-doo below.
We have to go to our rehearsal now.
We're about to go on stage before our rehearsal show,
and I'm super stressed out, and Hank's just, like, chilling.
—I'm looking up how many people in the United States are named Caroline: 138,000.
—Of course that's what you're doing.
Hey, thanks for wearing my, uh,
face on your torso, by the way.
A couple other things. I signed over 200,000 copies of the US edition of Turtles All the Way Down,
so hopefully you won't have trouble
finding an autographed one,
unless you live outside of the US or Canada,
in which case, I'm sorry.
Hello! Me-from-the-future here, because me-from-the-past forgot to tell you about the second thing,
which is that I wanted to share some of the reviews the book has gotten today.
They've all been really generous. The Wall Street Journal
called it "tender, wise, and hopeful."
The New York Times called it a "wrenching and revelatory novel."
It got starred reviews from Booklist and SLJ, and the Guardian said it "might be a new modern classic,"
which is a bit much, but you know what? I'll take it.
Alright, back to the past, which is in your present.
Alright, we just did our first warm-up show, Hank. How did it go?
—Bad!
—No! It went— It went alright!
—Heh, okay.
—Uh, you could kinda tell that we'd never rehearsed.
—Well, this was a rehearsal,
and I was somewhat surprised when I found out there were gonna be 150 people there.
—They were very nice, though.
—Oh, very, very nice.
Especially Olivia, who told me
all the words to my songs.
—Hank forgot the words to
every single one of his songs,
but fortunately, there was a young woman named Olivia in the front row, who had all of Hank's songs memorized,
so everything worked out better than expected.
I wouldn't actually say better than expected.
—[LAUGHS]
—I would say differently from expected.
—It worked out just fine.
Is this the final version of the book?
—It is.
—What does it look like with the dust cover off?
Oh, neat, there's a secret!
—There's a secret.
—[GASPS]
—There's a secret, yeah.
—I'm not gonna show you!
—It's pretty cool, right?
—That's great!
—Yeah. That was designed by people in Nerdfighteria.
—Why didn't you tell me about that?
We could've made merch from it.
—Oh, my God. We have merch from it: it's called Turtles All the Way Down.
It's available in bookstores everywhere.
Okay, Hank, I'm gonna ask you some questions from our audience that we didn't get to answer during the show.
If 2016 was a giant dumpster fire, what is a visual representation of 2017?
—Is it just, like, what's left after a dumpster fire?
—2017: the year of burnt garbage!
—Do you listen to music while
you're writing your books?
—This will surprise you, Hank, but I do.
Only the Mountain Goats.
—How does it feel to have Hank be a published author?
—I'm so psyched. I'm so happy. I'm so proud of Hank.
—John, If I was cast in a movie adaptation of your book, who would I play?
—I mean, that seems unlikely on a lot of levels.
—Can I be the tuatara?
—That's actually not a bad call.
Show me your best tuatara. [SNORTS]
—[NASAL VOICE] I've just got a neck cramp.
—Oh, my God, that's one of the most disturbing things I've ever seen.
I'm gonna put up a real tuatara. Let's go back-to-back.
Is it a good impression or not? You be the judge.
—But it has to have, like, some lines.
—It definitely does not have lines.
The whole point of the tuatara is
that it is a cold, dead-eyed—
—[EXAGGERATED PSEUDO-TEXAN ACCENT] Hello, Aza! I'm the tuatara! Heyyyyyyy!
—Oh, man.
—[IN ACCENT] I'm a living fossil!
—Again, Turtles All the Way Down is out now,
and you can go to the subreddit.
There is a link below if you wanna talk about spoilers; please don't talk about them in comments.
Thank you! Thank you for reading. DFTBA. Hank, I will continue to see you right now.